[Music]
those big sunglasses can't hide that the
actress who plays Jeffrey Dahmer's
mother in Netflix's monster is probably
familiar to lots of viewers here's where
you've likely seen her before Netflix's
new true crime series Dahmer monster the
Jeffrey Dahmer story once again seeks to
adapt the true story of the infamous
serial killer for the screen the series
was co-created by Ryan Murphy and Ian
Brennan the minds Behind series
including American Crime Story American
Horror Story and scream Queens Evan
Peters who fans May identify as
Quicksilver from the X-Men franchise
stars as Dahmer Murphy has stressed the
importance of centering Dahmer's victims
and their families as well as the
institutional racism and ineptitude that
allowed Dahmer to keep killing for as
long as he did the series goes back into
Dahmer's high school years and features
a crop of stars as the Disturbed
youngsters Guardians who fail to
understand what the young man would
become Richard Jenkins stars as Dahmer's
father Lionel and Molly Ringwald plays
his stepmother Shari his mother Joyce is
played by Penelope Anne Miller whose
first big roles were in the theater her
Broadway career began in a 1985
production of Biloxi Blues she reprized
the role in the 1988 film adaptation
alongside Matthew Broderick and she
earned a Tony nomination for the 1989
Broadway Revival of our town big film
roles followed suit and Miller starred
in a number of family-friendly flicks in
the late 80s in 1987 she co-starred in
Adventures in Babysitting as Chris's
frenzied friend Brenda in 2017 on the
movie's 30th Anniversary she reminisced
to E.T that was the beginning that was
the beginning of my career the next year
she appeared in big top peewee as Peewee
Herman's fiancee Winnie Johnson Miller
kicked off the 1990s by starring
alongside two gangster movie Legends the
LA native put on a thick New York accent
to play Marlon Brando's daughter in the
Freshman a crime comedy that had her
once again sharing scenes with Matthew
Broderick I don't know who they it was
in the United States is my point
she also co-starred with Robert De Niro
and the considerably more dramatic film
Awakenings based on neurologist Oliver
sack's Memoir of the same name the film
stars Robin Williams as a doctor and De
Niro as an Encephalitis patient Miller
plays another patient's daughter who
starts a romantic relationship with De
Niro's character Brando and De Niro
weren't the only big stars who Miller
rubbed shoulders with in 1990. that year
she also appeared alongside Arnold
Schwarzenegger in kindergarten cop in
1993 Miller worked with yet another
Godfather star Al Pacino in 1993's
Carlito's Way directed by Brian De Palma
the film follows a New York criminal
struggling to leave behind his
law-breaking ways for her role as
Carlito's girlfriend Gail Miller earned
a Golden Globe nomination for best
actress Miller was initially dubious
about the character who is a stripper
But ultimately it was too good an
opportunity to pass up she told the
Baltimore Sun I figured I could meet
with Pacino at least and he could see my
work I could establish a relationship
with him and Brian De Palma but I
realized that this was was a great meaty
role and that the stripping was such a
very small part of it Miller then went
on to star in the 1997 Creature Feature
The Relic after that she returned to
Broadway and made TV appearances in
series including the closer and
Desperate Housewives in 2011 she had a
supporting role in the artist the
nostalgic throwback to silent film era
Hollywood cleaned up during Awards
season winning three Golden Globe Awards
and five Academy Awards including best
picture in the film Miller plays Doris
the embattled wife of silent film star
George Valentin of the challenges of
Silent acting Miller told making of I
think the daunting task is to be
believable and authentic to the period
you don't want to overdo it and seem
like you're overacting or being gimmicky
Miller was perhaps the only artist cast
member to have any sort of Silent acting
experience she played silent film
actress Edna perviens in 1992's chaplain
alongside Robert Downey Jr
[Music]